yes absolutely
this narrative that having an abortion is the worst
most traumatic day of a woman's life is not at all backed by research
and it's a really harmful narrative
because the anti choice movement
uses it to fuel a stereotype that women regret their abortions
and therefore we should not allow women the choice to get one
which in the turnaway study
which is the largest study done
comparing women who were denied wanted abortions
versus women who received a wanted abortion
they talk about this
it's called the dignity of risk
that basically
women should have the right to make their own personal decisions
even decisions they might regret
however the research shows that regret is not the most common
or even close to the most common response to having an abortion
overwhelmingly
the most common emotion felt after having an abortion was relief
at 90% those who were denied an abortion
the most common emotions were sadness
followed by regret
the most common emotional response to having an abortion is actually none
over time two thirds of women say that they experience no
or very few emotions about the abortion anymore
they also talk about how this is because
women have a lot more going on in their lives than their abortion um
95% of women reported that having the abortion was the right decision for them
and if you're wondering about that remaining 5%
the 5% reported high community stigma
that their groups
their social groups shamed them and made them feel very bad about their abortion
and it LED them feeling like their decision to have an abortion
was very difficult
and that they somewhat regretted it
the women who had the hardest time emotionally
were those who placed the child for adoption
so this idea that we should just force women to have birth
because they can just give the child up for adoption
adoption is not a band aid for forced birth